Film Courage: When you write a first draft,
how detailed is that first draft?
Shawn Christensen co-writer/director of THE
VANISHING OF SIDNEY HALL Movie: How detailed…what
do you mean how detailed?
Film Courage: Well I know you talked about
previously off-camera you will go back over
something fairly soon but when you are first
writing, when you are creating this world,
when you’re sitting down how much are you
getting into the details of the characters
and really thinking about their backstory
or are you just kind of putting out a structure
(I know you don’t outline) of the story?
How much are you paying attention to certain
things?
Or are you just getting words out first?
Shawn Christensen: Well it depends on which
script.
It depends on where the story is coming from.
Generally speaking I don’t have a backstory
beyond a sentence or two.
I don’t know what they were like in 6th
grade or anything like that.
I just kind of take from people in real life
or combine people in real life or think of
people I know.
And again, I just balance these characters
off each other knowing that this one is sort
of feisty and this one is sort of mellow and
this one is sort of this and then you can
add on the second or the third adjective sort
of as you go but I think in the beginning
if I’m going to introduce a character that
I’ve never written in my life and I say
Joe, 25, persistent…I don’t know, I’ll
say two adjectives and then I’ll just move
forward.
That’s it.
It’s real, real quick.
And then I don’t necessarily have to deliver
on those adjectives if I feel like it’s
going in another direction, maybe he’s not
persistent?
Maybe he’s lackluster?
Maybe he’s lazy?
I don’t know.
I have to like write him out a little bit.
I have to let him talk in order to know.
But the dynamic between characters is important
and the chemistry so I always start there,
that’s where I start.
And the story and the concept that I have
is like a sentence.
It’s not an outline.
That’s not detailed or in-depth.
The first draft will be detailed to the extent
it needs to be in order to be concise, to
the point, and not dragging anywhere where
we don’t need to be in particularly in the
action.
So when we enter this room, am I going to
tell you that it’s got blue walls and a
couch?
No.
Because the characters are more important
and the room is for the director, it’s not
my job, I’m screenwriter.
The room is for the director to decide.
If you’re the director and the screenwriter,
great or whatever but people respond to characters
first and foremost.
And so that’s just really the most detailed
part of my screenplay.
I would say is the action is the briefest
part of my script.